Asia is about to get kind of crazy with
military stuff the U.S and its allies
are spending billions and billions of
dollars to militarize this region
they're sending missiles and other
weapons to Japan they're operating new
military bases in the Philippines
they're creating this joint submarine
force with the UK and Australia so that
more submarines with nuclear weapons can
be patrolling these Waters they're doing
this because they are afraid of China
China who is a rising power who's
getting really really good at military
stuff and it's kind of freaking the us
out they're also doing this to let China
know that if they invade Taiwan the U.S
and its allies will be right there ready
to retaliate in that sense they're
trying to deter an attack on Taiwan but
to China all of this just looks like
encirclement and so once again we see
the Paradox of deterrence in
international relations where sometimes
you can provoke the very conflict you're
trying to deter